how's everybody doing tonight whoo all
right whoa we can work with the whoo we
are we are live streaming this on my
channel can you guys make a little noise
for the people at home that are naked
watching this I assume that people watch
politics naked I am very excited to be
here first off what you guys are
obviously doing something right on this
campus that I don't see anything burning
right now what's going on here shouldn't
you guys be burning things or otherwise
you know we didn't have to pay six
hundred thousand dollars for for
protection like they did when when Ben
Shapiro was that it was at Berkeley last
week we have a great event
oh hello we've got a mic - all right
pretty good we have a great event for
you the two guys that I'm sitting
between right now are really I believe
at the forefront of this fight that
we're having for free speech it's crazy
to me but actually that that you guys
have to come out to an event like this
that what they say about college
students you know that you guys have
become increasingly intolerant I saw a
study today 51% of college students say
it's okay to shout down a speaker they
disagree with we will welcome every and
all questions that you guys have at the
end I I completely I'm a free speech
absolutist and that's how we're gonna
treat this event tonight so to start I'm
very excited because the administrators
here at Harvard actually gave me a list
of topics that were allowed to discuss
we will go with what we said was okay
now before we start though you know what
I like when I do these events is that
you know we talk a lot about diversity
these days and you know there's a
certain type of diversity that a certain
type of person likes which means I can
look out and I can see people of
different colors and different races and
male and female and probably different
sexualities and all that but that's not
really the diversity that I care about
myself
I actually care
about diversity of thought I think that
that's actually much more important than
the diversity that you are you're born
with your immutable characteristics and
so for example how many Nazis do we have
here a show of hands would be fine guys
are coming with me slowly okay
yeah diversity of thought is what it's
all about and and these two gentlemen
have have a wide variety of thoughts so
without further ado I want to I want to
start with Brett here because you have
been sort of at the forefront of what's
going on in in the college space
basically you have had to resign from
Evergreen State College you were a
biology professor there you have had to
resign because you were anti-racist
actually against racism you wrote a
letter against racism your career has
consistently been about at the racism
and you've been a progressive basically
for 20 years fair to say about 20 years
life your whole life okay but tonight
you are sort of gonna break some news so
you just had a settlement with Evergreen
State five hundred thousand dollars but
you and your wife are stepping away from
the University and again this was a
fight over anti racism did I set you up
there yeah that's a pretty fair pretty
fair introduction I was opposing a
clearly segregationist policy and I was
protested very vigorously as many people
saw on on YouTube and this resulted in a
pitched battle between me largely and
the college administration over the
treatment of faculty members by
protesters
and in any case my wife and I we never
ended up filing suit against the college
because in Washington you have to file a
tort claim and then wait 60 days before
you can file suit but that suit was
about to be filed and we met with the
college and chose the only
good path for us which was to resign our
positions which the the college very
much wanted us to to leave because our
presence was very awkward and what they
wish to continue doing would have been
difficult if we had still been around so
I think my wife Heather huiying who was
also a professor of biology summed it up
very very well when she said that we had
effectively been paid to leave a burning
building the building is still on fire
and we have now left him so people here
all right well you guys got five hundred
thousand dollars that sounds like
something it's a nice chunk of change
that I would imagine anyone out here
would be happy about five hundred
thousand dollars but think about it in
your battle to say what you believe in
to fight policies that are truly racist
that we're happening on this campus it
costs you and your wife your jobs
it's an incredible situation that you've
been put in yeah to tenured
professorship that could have supported
our family for the rest of our careers
another 15 or 20 years were lost to this
and and $500,000 sounds like a lot of
money and indeed I think what was
important to us was that it is enough
that you can tell that the college
understood that it had done wrong things
and that it feared going to trial and I
think it in particular feared the
process of discovery
because as foolish as people were on
video they were even more foolish in
writing and that was available through
public records requests over the the
campus email server but there was a lot
more to be discovered in depositions and
and in other correspondence so and in
any case the the fact of the settlement
does say that the college made terrible
errors and that some in some way it is
aware of that though it will not
formally admit it but effectively it's
given my wife and and me a couple years
to figure out what to do next in lieu of
the professorships that we've we've had
to leave well I have an idea I wasn't
planning on doing this but what do you
guys think you think we could get this
professor in exile a gig here at Harvard
you think that's can you guys write a
letter or
[Applause]
Steve yeah what is going on on college
campuses I mean this situation right
here yeah we were talking about it all
day long it yeah it's crazy no it's
completely crazy I mean what's going on
in college campuses I think is a
microcosm of what's going on in the
country in general and the way I would
put it is there's a serious battle of
ideas going on in this country and if we
want to save free speech we have to
understand the ideas that underlie free
speech we have to understand where free
speech comes from why is it a value is
it a right you know we are my position
obviously is that it's a it's a
fundamental individual right but it's
also a value it's a value to every
individual human being in this society
and I don't think people are taught that
anymore in fact I'm sure they're not
taught that anymore and what we saw
happen at Evergreen is a good example of
what happens when you teach young people
ideas that are contrary to freedom I
mean there and there are a number of
ideas that that we see taught or that we
see manifested on college campuses today
I mean you could put it I mean
throughout the entire country tribalism
is one the idea that that individuals
are really essentially meaningless and
that they're there have they given
meaning only to the extent that they
they belong to some group whether it's a
racial group a group based on gender a
group based on class you know this is
what identity politics is all about it's
about fracturing the country into
warring factions and warring groups and
there are whole philosophies that
subscribe to the idea that that's
essentially what society is
post-modernism is it is a good example
of that multiculturalism I think are
both good examples of that and when you
attack the individual and the
sovereignty of the individual or if you
attack the ability of the individual to
think we have all we see ideas taught I
think on college campuses constantly
today that attack reason they attack
free will the ability that you could the
idea that you can choose your own ideas
if we get rid of free will what's the
point of having free speech so that I
mean there's much
more to talk about but I mean what we
are ultimately seeing is the
manifestation of bad ideas that have
been taught now for generations and one
of the worst ideas I think that we see
and that we really saw in Evergreen is
the idea that speech is a threat it's
somehow a threat to your safety and we
see that in the whole idea of safe
spaces trigger warnings I think
microaggressions just the idea that
speech is of variation or a type of
force and that if you don't like if
you're offended by ideas that's the same
thing as being harmed if you really
believe that you are going to attack a
guy like Brett Weinstein when he says
what you say is the wrong thing although
I'll just emphasize I think he said
everything I think everything you said
was right Brett but but obviously there
are people who don't and if you don't
teach people how to deal with contrary
ideas and how to think they're either at
of fear or out of animosity going to
attack people when they speak and we saw
a little example of that at Evergreen
but we're seeing examples of that all
over not just on college campuses by the
way I mean Charlottesville I think is an
example of that all throughout the
country
yeah and I'll go on the record is saying
now that now that this is settled for
you I mean it seems to me that the
school is actually gonna just rot from
the inside now they've they've staked
out a position and got rid of of an
intellectual of two intellectually
honest professors in the name of all of
this political correctness and I suspect
five years from now you'll look back and
be doing great things and go man I got
well it's it's actually already clear
that I got out at the right time so I
know that it looks from video that I was
opposed by a great many people and it
was a large number of people but it was
a very small percentage of the students
on the campus and the faculty is
actually deeply divided about what
happened so to make a long story short I
have lots of friends left on the inside
who are forwarding me you know my email
was cut off within seconds you know
before the ink was even dry on the
settlement because the the
administration wished to sever that
connection but people keep forwarding me
things and if there's one thing that's
absolutely clear from the traffic that
remains on the inside of the college the
college learned zero from this event it
is
anything more convinced of the rightness
of the direction that it was headed and
it's phony vision of equity and so it's
making the same move that it has made
since since May which is to double down
yet again on the same wrongheaded
policies yeah and what's interesting
about Brett I think is that he says this
as a lefty you say this as as a
committed lefty and progressive we were
talking about it today but what's really
interesting is I don't I personally
don't put the blame on the college
students like you got well you guys are
here so you're your defenders of free
speech you you understand the exchange
that we're trying to have but I don't
put the blame on the a lot of these
college kids going through this because
we were talking today about how
privately you've had a ton of support
from faculty and yet publicly they don't
because even if they in their own hearts
and in their own minds they believe that
what you did was right they believe in
these ideas they don't want to be
subjected to the same monster so by you
leaving and them staying quiet
ultimately it will have to come for them
as well or they can remain silent the
rest of their lives as professors which
is pretty sad well I will say I think
many of them correctly understood that
they would not be able to withstand what
comes back if you stand up that the the
epithets that are directed at you are
tactical
they don't have to be true and so what
comes back is designed to stigmatize you
to make you unhireable to undermine the
security that you're depending on and so
I can't really fault people for
recognizing that that's an actual hazard
I certainly wish they had more courage
but but I'm not surprised that they
don't the correct response to that for
anybody facing this at another college
the correct response is for people to
stand up together that's the only thing
that's likely to work and I wish that
they had recognized that early enough to
to save evergreen which i think is
probably now impossible so just to be
clear since we are live streaming this
you are not a white supremacist you are
not a white supremacist I am NOT a white
supremacist white supremacist I was
flirting with it but now you're out okay
great that almost sounded like an
applause for white supremacy but no no
people can I make a point though so this
is I think though I mean I agree with
what Brett said that people have to
stand up and they have to have the
courage the moral courage to stand up
and speak out for somebody like Brett
who speaks up but I think there's more
going on there which is there's there's
a there's an issue of I would call
intellectual courage or maybe it's maybe
you could put it like this self-doubt if
you buy into a lot of the ideas for
which you were attacked or if you buy
into the I would call it an ideology or
philosophy that that that you were I
think opposing when you and you can
disagree with me obviously if you think
I'm getting this wrong but that you were
opposing which was the I mean it's it's
what ultimately led to the day of
absence being turned into something that
is I think sensible in the context of
its Douglas Turner Awards playwright day
of absence which is the the play is
about a segregated town in which all the
black people leave and then all the the
racist white people find that they can't
you know shine the shoes or get anything
done anymore and it's it's a nice
parable on you know what happens when
when you when you get rid of or when the
people who you hold in contempt and
criticize finally say to hell with it
and leave just to be absolutely clear
for the 20 or so years before this that
the school did it and the black students
left or the black students or students
of color who ever considered themselves
allies or wanted to believe in this
cause you had no issue with that it was
only when it was flipped and and white
students were basically told not to come
to campus well I mean this might be too
much inside baseball but at some level
what troubled me was that one population
was telling another population not to
come to campus and it it was voluntary
but it was very clear that you were
making a statement if you showed up on
campus and you were wiped then you were
essentially saying I'm not an ally to
people of color and for for me that was
a problem because I am an ally to people
of color and I did not wish to be forced
to demonstrate that by leaving as
somebody else's idea I certainly have no
problem with people AB scenting
themselves from anything as a protest I
I support that I don't know how
effective a protest it was in the years
beforehand in other words the the
Douglas Turner Ward play is predicated
on a town and the black population
leaving the town makes this point I was
afraid in the years that I was at the
college prior to this year that in in
fact the day of absence when people of
color left inadvertently made the wrong
point because it didn't cause the
college to come to a halt right and so
I'm not sure it was an effective protest
but I certainly had no objection to
people absenting themselves but here's
the the point I was gonna make and I
think that's a good point and it
dovetails with what I was gonna say
although I you can disagree obviously
Brett but but I'm not convinced I mean
in the in the context in which that play
was written it makes perfectly good
sense because you have a circumstance in
which a group of people black people are
actually literally being oppressed or or
the affective or you know effectively
the same thing and in that context yes
they should go on strike so to speak
they should leave I'm not convinced that
it applies you know in today's or in
fact I don't think it applies at all in
today's world at Evergreen State College
but to reverse that is completely crazy
it's then to say but now we're gonna
turn it on its head and tell all the
white people to leave campus it makes no
sense even if you accept the logic of
the play it's just crazy it's like and
and it's and it becomes a kind of
intimidation effort to tell people of a
certain race you all you all should
leave campus because you're all
collectively guilty for I would put it
the sins of your forefathers so to speak
of the sins of people who aren't even
alive today who lived you know years and
years or decades and decades ago and
this is part of the problem we've
accepted this idea of I would call it
racial guilt and it flows in all kinds
of different directions it's not
necessarily just white people that are
supposed to feel guilty it's all and
this is what identity politics in
intersectionality is all about is you
can't even keep track of who's supposed
to feel guilty but to circle back to the
original point that you made about your
colleagues not standing up I think part
of the problem is a lot of them or I
would say people intellectuals in this
country have accepted a lot of those
ideas and if you accept those ideas if
you accept the idea I
put it this way that America is an
inherently racist nation that oppresses
all minorities if you accept that and
you think that that everything is about
racism I think you are gonna fall for
these ideas I think you will have a hard
time standing up for somebody who says
no I'm not just you know an example of
my race I'm an individual human being
and I deserve to be judged that way it
doesn't mean there's no racism in
America yes there's racism in America
but that's a very different thing from
saying that America is inherently racist
and everybody is a racist if you accept
that latter point I think you end up
with the kind of situation that happened
at Evergreen and is happening in a lot
of campuses yeah and you guys may find
this kind of interesting we were told
and I can be corrected if mistaken here
that this event was not originally we
thought it was going to be open for
everybody so that's what we posted
online and and wherever else and and
then we were told by the University that
free speech events only free speech
events are only allowed to be students
which is really an interesting position
so if we had had a talk with Brett about
biology then non students could be here
or if we had a talk with Steve about
about law or whatever else then non
students can be here so I was getting
tweets from people saying I'm here and I
can't come in which is an interesting
position even that it sort of puts free
speech on its heels and I say this as
someone that's been welcomed into
Harvard and I'm and I'm thrilled to be
here and it sounds like the school
basically has been pretty good on this
but even that these little subtle things
that pop up quit free speech on the
defensive well actually I think it
brings up two issues that would be very
fruitful for us to talk about one of
them is you know yes if I was to be here
talking about biology presumably letting
the public in wouldn't be a problem even
though frankly biology is way more
dangerous than free speech most people
are at least in principle agreed on free
speech but when people start talking
about biology of sex gender population
people get very nervous and so in part
what I don't think has been well
understood about the Evergreen situation
is that the fact that I'm a biologist
was not incidental even if many of the
students who were protesting me didn't
realize
that what had actually brought them to
my classroom was the biology the fact is
biology is deeply politically incorrect
and that deep political incorrectness
both caused my my classroom frankly to
be kind of a popular place because I was
honest with students about you know what
are you what is a human being you give
an example of that type of political
incorrectness this is one of the things
that I've been talking about on the show
and I had James d'amour the the X Google
employee who wrote you know who wrote
that piece after the diversity memo and
basically that it seems almost to me
that biology and science are about to
come crashing into the sort of social
justice post-modernism because these
things cannot exist together they're in
direct cut out that Eric Weinstein my
brother and Jordan Peterson both
predicted that biologists would be next
on the list of people to come after sure
yeah let's so let's do the easy one sex
and gender yes all right
you might all want to sit down but okay
so sex and gender is is gender a
so-called social construct right is it
just simply the fact that you've been
handed a designation at birth and that
this designation therefore has some
implications for you that you're just as
well off to jettison and do something
else
well my opinion you are actually pretty
wise to think about whether you want to
accept which you've been handed but
you've been handed a lot by biology and
let me just take you a little ways down
this road so think about the biology II
documentaries that you've seen right
you're very familiar with display of
sexual displays very flashy males
displaying for very drab females right
well you will notice that does not
exactly remind you of human beings that
in fact if one of the sexes is flashy
it's females and males are more drab
right now what comes along with
flashiness in the animal kingdom is that
males in these species where males are
flashy mate indiscriminately they don't
really care because they're not
investing anything other than gametes
where
females in these species are extremely
choosy right so then that would suggest
that females who are flashy in humans
because of a partial sex role reversal
might mate indiscriminately not true in
humans right so the sex role reversal is
only a partial thing and you might say
well this is all the result of human
culture something we've imposed on top
of the biology not true there are 4,000
species of mammals in the world there is
exactly one mammal species in which
mammary glands remain enlarged when not
lactating
that's humans so that means that
somewhere in the last six million years
since we branched off from chimpanzees
we have been modified such that females
have a display characteristic which you
will notice is a focus for straight men
right and so if you can see how
politically correct this gets inside of
a minute or two because now we're
talking about the fact that breasts are
clearly biology that they have something
to do with a sex role reversal within
human beings and then the cherry on top
for this discussion is well which sex is
choosy in human beings
they both are but they choose for
different things now I'm not telling you
that any of this is something that you
have to adhere to we are free going
forward to retool these things because
we don't live in our ancestral
environment but the idea that these
things didn't come from selection acting
in our ancestral environment is nuts
this came from biology and it is what it
is well I also know it's politically
correct because you called the mammary
glands and not boobs well either the way
we're allowed to say boobs here right I
mean we can we can call them boobs not
offending anybody I know boobs are
suddenly very offensive but I only say
boobs when I talk about people wielding
Authority in an inappropriate way yes
you see what they've done straight men
can't talk about boobs any more properly
that is a sad state of affairs what
about what about on the legal side of
all of this you know I was thinking so
so Shapiro went to Berkeley now Ben I I
know Ben we've become friends Ben
whether you agree with him or not and I
had great disagreements with him on my
show I mean on very personal things on
we've talked about gay marriage we've
talked about abortion I'm pro-choice
he's pro-life etc etc but I noticed that
the reaction after the Berkeley event
last week was a lot of people are saying
well you know it was actually pretty
good because only five people were
arrested there wasn't a ton of damage
$600,000 had to secure that event I said
to you today yeah I looked online you
can buy pocket constitutions for a
dollar I mean it would have been better
to just hand out six hundred thousand of
those you know so when in a way does
that show that we've sort of already
lost here yeah that to have this guy who
whether you like him or not is really
just a mainstream conservative yeah
basically that we've lost because these
events now eventually schools can't
schools and cities just simply can't
afford the type of security that will be
needed for mainstream thinkers we're not
talking about some you know off the
range
yeah and that's I think that's what
you'll ultimately see is if it costs
that much to have talks at school
schools or just say nobody can speak now
and and they'll find ways to do it
there's ways legally that even a public
school could do that but so I mean one
way to think about this is what happened
I mean I think again I'll use Evergreen
because Brett's here but there are other
examples you could give Middlebury
Berkeley back in February Claremont
McKenna College with Heather McDonald
all of those in Evergreen are examples
of essentially people who believe that
it's OK to react to speech that you
don't like with violence or with force
or really with action at all getting the
upper hand and then cowing
administration's who then appease them
and allow them to get away with that if
that continues I mean one of two things
happens either they end up successfully
preventing the event from happening at
all they drum it out and and people just
can't speak because of the threat of
violence or the administration's have to
spend so much money to get because at
the at the Berkeley talk with Shapiro
they were there were cops out and riot
gear and that was the only way they
could keep the peace now why does that
happen
happens for a number of reasons one is
that administration's and the police and
the government appease those who use
force against others and they allow them
to continue and I think part of the
reason is that they lot of them tacitly
agree with what they're doing another is
that is that is that we don't our
governments are not taking this kind of
thing seriously I mean you know an tyfa
so it's crazy that anti-fog can go
around and and create a gang war out of
ending the world white supremacist I
mean it doesn't matter I'm not picking
sides in this I'm just saying that
anybody who's willing to meet free
speech with violence has to be arrested
they have to be treated like criminal
gangs that's essentially what they are
if they're if they're allowed to get
away with that either they can prevent
the event or they can cost the school so
much money that it becomes moot whether
you're allowed to do the event or not
and they've ultimately won and and so
our governments have to take that
seriously and our schools have to take
that seriously but but for a variety of
reasons they've had their hands tied I'm
sorry to say I actually think and we
should talk more about this one of the
reasons that they've had their hands
tied because while I'm completely
sympathetic with Brett's perspective and
I applaud the fact that you sued
evergreen over it I think more people
need to do that in order to protect free
speech in a way and I'll say this about
Harvard it's it's understandable when
universities take the position that they
have to say only allow students in with
student IDs they that they have to have
a serious police presence that they have
to spend half a million dollars on
police presence because if they're
essentially forced to have these events
and if no if the if the government is
not taking care of this they've got to
protect people in some way right so part
of what I think has to be part of the
conversation is how have the courts
dealt with these kinds of threats to
free speech and have they adult with it
the right way I think the answer is
ultimately no but it's a broader
discussion but it'd be great if we could
discuss that a bit more too but but yeah
if if this sort of thing is allowed to
continue you know there's there's two
ways government can stamp out free
speech one is through censorship one is
the other is through inaction and I
think what we're seeing off
today is in action and it has the same
result yeah well there's so much here
because we can talk about this from the
perspective of a professor in exile and
we can talk about this from the position
of a legal expert but even today did any
of you guys see this that at Reed
College there was a class that was it's
on Greco and Roman history and basically
a bunch of kids just ran up to the front
and started you know screaming about the
the racist history of of Greek
civilization which has given us pretty
much every philosophy that we have here
in the West and sort of the reaction to
it was like oh well maybe there's a
point there that was kind of what I got
online not that you can get a lot of
truth through Twitter that's the
smartest thing that I'm gonna say here
tonight but but this concept I mean
that's what these this ideology is sort
of trying to steal from you guys imagine
I mean you guys are at Harvard right
like this is this is the place do or
your minds to figure out what you
believe in how to think and all of those
things imagine if you were going to a
class in just a bunch of students who
thought that they knew what was right or
what you should be taught just demanded
the audience just demanded the the
microphone from the professor I mean
it's crazy but we've sort of just given
in in all of these ways so we have
students kind of giving in we have
professors giving in I think on the
legal front we're kind of giving in how
do we start some of the pushback I think
we're starting it actually well I would
actually argue that our problem is is
bigger than then this discussion
suggests so far because well what we're
hobbled by is an 18th century notion of
what threatens speech and we have 21st
century threats to speech that are just
unanticipated so what we're really
dealing with you know evergreen it
happens is a state college which means
that free speech was an issue for me and
one of the theories along which a case
could easily have proceeded is a federal
case about government oppression of free
speech that was one of the possibilities
under consideration had Evergreen been
private that wouldn't have been possible
and there's no reason from the point of
view of the value of a cow
your university that it should matter
whether or not the institution is public
the real question is do we have the
tools to have the discussions that we
need to have to bring civilization
forward and I think it's actually
fascinating that we can talk about this
here having been invited to Harvard by
libertarians because libertarians of
course traditionally are deeply
skeptical of bringing government
regulation in to solve a problem on the
other hand our problems at the moment
may be as threatened by Google which you
know in many ways is bigger than a
nation and more powerful than a nation
in terms of its ability to shape our
discussion and our thought processes and
so we are now as a civilization running
the risk that there will be a discussion
at Google in which it will be decided
that some set of ideas is to be promoted
and some other set of ideas is to be
down regulated and that that will begin
to affect what we're capable of
collectively thinking and because
Google's private we can't invoke the
First Amendment as a protection and
there's no reason that we should feel
less threatened by that so what I'm
imagining is likely to happen is people
who have a libertarian bent are actually
liable to want to see a broadening of
the concept of free speech they're going
to want to see government empowered to
protect us from private entities like
Google that may be a greater threat than
than any nation really could be can i
yeah I think what you're seeing there is
a is a progressive giving some props to
you libertarian that seems like it's
where they're out of applause okay
[Applause]
this is one of the criticisms we've
gotten to these events is that hasn't
been enough disagreement so I wanna try
to thank you disagree with me we were
back there arm wrestling before and Bret
kept winning so now maybe I can get it
no but so I actually think that's wrong
but so in fact I would actually say it's
the opposite that I'm not a libertarian
I'm an Objectivist to follow Irvine
Rand's philosophy I don't want to get
into now the distinctions there other
than to say that this is the objectivism
is a it's a whole philosophical take on
life but but it's I think it's exactly
the opposite of that I would say that
the real problem so I'll take it in two
steps first with education the
government controls education from top
to bottom in this country it's not just
at the college level it's at that it's
at the primary and secondary level as
well and so one of the weird things
about this whole debate about free
speech on campus is while we are
rightfully I think complaining that
somebody like ben shapiro is not allowed
to speak or Ann Coulter or whatever or
not I don't like Anna Coulter a tall
bench peer I think is very bright but
but leaving that aside I'm it's
ultimately the choice of the collagen it
should be up to them whether or invite
speakers or not but this is I look at
that as it's like it's a tiny little
sliver of what is happening in school
today think about this so meanwhile
everybody's fighting about Ben Shapiro
we have essentially government
determining from kindergarten all the
way up to 12th grade what every student
is taught and that is a huge either I
think it's a huge challenge to free
thought and free speech that government
gets to determine that that we don't
have the kind of you talk about
diversity and competition in the realm
of ideas today that we should and I
think that's part of the reason that we
have students being turned out in droves
who actually you know they can't think
they can't write they can't speak
they're they're nowhere near as
intelligent as they should be in the
solution to that is to privatize
education so that's one component of it
I mean there's a much more that we could
say about that but on the issue of
Google and the private companies I don't
think that that's right to call them a
threat to free speech at all and here's
the reason so that I mean there a number
of reasons number one a private company
cannot can
roll what people think only government
can use the force of law to restrict
what people can say and think it's only
possible for governments to do that
wait let's pause there there a second
because do you think it's possible that
Google is now getting so big that the
information that we all get is now
basically controlled by two or three
companies but Google's really ahead oh I
don't think it's possible but but here's
how I think I think you have to look at
it you have to take a broader more
historical view I mean you could have
said the exact same thing about radio
when it came out then it was supplanted
by TV and then guess what TV was only
three networks right that was government
controlled and then what did you get you
got two things you got talk radio
competing with it and you got cable
competing with it so in you know a
matter of like a decade or so the
supposed monopolies within broadcast TV
was destroyed by cable companies and by
talk radio and everybody thought oh my
god the cable companies are getting too
big then internet came along and
destroyed that and even once the
internet came along you have constant
disruption even within that space now
yes does it look like Google controls
all the world's information yes right
now for like the last year or so when
Google has become ascendant I think it's
easy for people if you only focus on
that to think that they control the
world's information I don't think they
can stay in that position one of the
reasons that I'm a huge supporter of
capitalism is that I think it's great to
have the free flow of capital and
Finance to finance people like you let's
say or anybody who wants to compete with
YouTube and create a new company but
leaving that aside I mean and I think
that will ultimately happen if enough
people are dissatisfied with with
YouTube let's say or with Facebook
you'll see competition arise in that
space just like Apple knocked over or
what Microsoft knocked over IBM
everybody thought that was impossible
then Apple knocked over not Microsoft
everybody thought that was impossible
then Samsung is now in and they're
actually the leading probably seller of
you know what used to be or what's what
are now smartphones and used to be
iPhones I mean this constant competition
throughout the economy in general well
one thing you have to keep in mind when
we talk about and look I'm sympathetic
to what's going on with you I think it
sucks what YouTube is doing with you D
monetizing your videos I think it's a
colossal II stupid but we have to draw a
distinction between what is what is
smart for a private company to do and
what is a real
threat to our freedoms for a private
company to do but we also have to look
at the other side of this it's really
wrong to say I disagree with what Google
is doing in one small sliver but I'm
going to ignore the fact that Google
just Google and I Apple two companies
have probably brought more information
to more people in a shorter period of
time than any other entity in the entire
history of mankind everybody carries
around with them a phone which which to
me is basically a magical device that
allows us to access all the world's
information in a few clicks of our
finger that is absolutely astounding you
can't ignore that if you're gonna talk
about the the supposedly negative impact
that Google and and all these company
companies have had you've got to look at
the positive impact and people are
looking at it way too narrowly but the
salient point to take away is this only
government can really clamp down on your
free speech part private companies it's
not able they're not able to do that
they're able to ruin you know they're
able to ruin their own companies they're
able to do really stupid things they're
able to lose their customers or they're
able to win over a lot of customers who
think the wrong things and it's our job
to convince them to change their minds
if facebook is spewing crap which I
don't think it necessarily is it's
everybody's job out there to convince
people who continue to use Facebook and
Twitter and consume all of that crap to
convince them not to do that even people
want to consume that that's what they
ultimately want to consume it's
interesting because I can really see
both sides of this argument I think it's
a principled argument either way I mean
look note first off no one's forcing me
to be on YouTube and it's a voluntary
service and you know I would like a
little more transparency with YouTube
I'm sure most of you guys probably would
like a little more transparency too and
yet the libertarian side of me I don't
want the government to come crashing in
and tell this company what to do so
there there's an there's two sort of
competing factors there at play but yes
I think ultimately capitalism do you
want Donald Trump to be deciding what's
on YouTube because that's all to me and
that if he's not the best example or
best argument against government control
of any form of media I would say the
entire continent I don't I cannot
imagine what is but No
Bruntlett yeah I want no one's ever said
that before I I don't disagree with you
that at least in principle if history is
any guide if Google overstepped its
bounds and even if it doesn't sooner or
later will be toppled by somebody else
and so there won't be one entity
persistently in control
on the other hand if all of those
entities are market-driven
then whatever it is that they are
attempting to accomplish in restricting
our speech and you know from what I
understand from the the Google memo
episode Google like evergreen is
wrongheaded and it is attempting to
deploy a very naive understanding of the
world and hard-coded into the structure
of in Google's case what it is that we
are what you can make a living putting
on YouTube for example but my point is
even if Google is toppled the same
forces that caused Google to be doing
what it's doing will be in charge and
what we really need is a principle that
says that we have a right to discuss
anything right
including wrongheaded things or things
that sound wrongheaded and turn out not
to be but we have a right and in fact we
have a need to be able to discuss those
things in order for civilization to
navigate and it doesn't make sense for
any entity to block that whether it be
governmental or whether it be these mega
corporations and so you know net
neutrality is a good test case net
neutrality is an idea that nobody should
be in charge of which bits have priority
and really nobody should be in charge of
which ideas have priority to the extent
that idea spreads it is an idea worth
hearing
it may be vile and it needs to be
repelled but to be silenced by an
algorithm is very very dangerous too
frankly the biotic mechanisms that human
beings use to figure out how to stop
doing what they've been doing and move
into a new niche and we are in danger of
for short-term economic reasons
taking temporarily true things and
writing them into a code so that we can
no longer escape yeah if I could just
put that a little more in in layman's
terms I mean in effect what's happening
right now with with Google and with the
algorithm is that the system that's
giving you the information that's
allowing you to get you to
videos that's allowing you google
something that's all showing the
information after is now we know I mean
there's there's basic evidence and this
is exactly what tomorrow was talking
about there's basic evidence that this
is now being manipulated because of
these diversity memos that they're
passing around Google it doesn't sound
like like something that's so inherently
evil but there's an incredible danger
there that we are gonna hardwired false
information basically into the system
that is giving us search results which
is incredibly dangerous but we don't
have to talk too much about Trump but
for just a moment where is Trump on this
free speech thing because there's
something kind of there's something kind
of interesting here that the Trump
supporters seem to be at least from for
the most part on the right side of this
and yet there is a obviously a piece of
Trump that is a real authoritarian that
probably wouldn't have a problem taking
away certain people's free speech yeah I
definitely think Trump is I would put
him as an authoritarian at heart or thus
he I think has the soul of a dictator
ultimately and and but the one so if
it's any if it's pretty doable though
you can say that in America nobody's
it's any consolation I don't think he's
fundamentally different than a lot of
presidents that we've had now he's he's
definitely different a lot of ways he's
way more overtly or authoritarian many
politicians out there are authoritarian
by authoritarian what I mean ultimately
is they think it's up to the government
to essentially tell you how to live your
life and how to what to think what to
say what actions you're allowed to take
in your life and that essentially it's
the rule of men over the rule of law or
the rule of people over the rule of law
meaning the decisions of the the
government officials are what controls
your life rather than any kind of a
principle the proper principles
individual rights although there's way
more to say about that but I mean if you
look at what Trump has done he hasn't
done or said anything that it's really
fundamental fundamentally different than
a lot of presidents have done so Trump
attacks the mainstream media attacks CNN
Obama attacked Fox as fake fake news I
don't care which of those I frankly
think they're both you know sometimes
good and oftentimes horrible but it's
really the same thing with Obama
that too to Fox and Trump saying that
about CNN it's not fundamentally
different I think that there's all
there's a there's a certain kind of
hysteria around Trump a lot of it for
good reasons he is as I said he's way
more overtly authoritarian than I think
previous presidents have been but he
hasn't adopted or nor does he support
policies that are fundamentally any
difference so the way I've often put it
is we don't have a Trump problem we have
a free-speech problem and by extension
we have a freedom problem people don't
understand what freedom really means in
this country and then what you get is
the factional conflict with left
attacking whatever the the right you
know the conservative president is and
the right attacking whoever the the the
liberal president is but both of them
are saying essentially the same thing
and it's really just my guys in office
uncomfortable with him controlling
things versus the other guy right now in
terms of Trump supporters I mean I don't
really think that the right is for a
long time I thought the right was better
on free speech than the left I don't
really think that anymore because I
don't think there's a real principled
distinction between the two at least
broadly speaking that doesn't mean there
aren't good voices on the left and good
voices on the right there definitely are
right but the simple truth is that the
Trump supporters aren't stopping people
from coming to college camp well no
that's definitely true but a lot of I've
heard so recently and I mean this gets
back to some disagreement that Brent and
I had before I've seen many voices rise
up on the right saying yeah I'm in favor
of a free market but I think the
government needs to clamp down on Google
Facebook and and YouTube and it's so
obvious to me that that the only reason
these voices are doing that is because
the you know Google Facebook YouTube
Silicon Valley stands for a quote
progressive worldview they don't like
that worldview so they want to clamp
down on it it's no different from people
on the left saying I don't think
corporations should have the freedom to
spend money on political speech I hate
the Koch brothers it's the exact same
attitude on both sides and and it's
totally unprincipled in my view now you
know maybe we can we should discuss that
or disagree more but I think you see
exactly the same view on both sides and
what it amounts to is ultimately I don't
like what that guy's saying so I want to
clamp
I mean that's not a principled view of
free speech but it takes I think a whole
lot more understanding of what free
speech really means it's not just
ultimately about the freedom to speak
you also need the freedom to take
certain kinds of actions you need the
freedom to spend money you need I mean
you I think you are the perfect example
of this if you don't have if people can
put a restriction on the the the the
your financial life and and as as
YouTube essentially is doing that's
gonna have an impact on your on your
speech now there's a difference when the
government is doing it versus a private
company yeah if we really want free
speech we've got a support freedom
across the board I'll quote on Rand on
this a free mind and a free market or
corollaries they both go together if you
don't have one you're not gonna have the
other and it goes in both directions
yeah so since we're talking to college
students I think it's interesting when I
go to colleges because you guys to me
are growing up in the age where everyone
is outraged about everything constantly
I mean we wake up and you're suddenly
outraged about someone who you never
heard of that said something that you
don't really understand and you can
spend all day long being outraged about
it and tweeting about all that now you
just survived the outrage machine I mean
you really did you came out on the other
side and you'll figure out what's next
for you but how much does that that's
sort of now look we're all free speech
absolutist here so I if people want to
be outraged you can be outraged
obviously I'm not trying to stop people
from being outraged but I a sense that
our outrage meter is so out of whack
right now we can't figure out what real
threats are so to bring this back to
boobs or as you call mammary glands I
mean even that that silly moment happens
on CNN a couple days ago and clay Travis
says boobs okay the guy believed you
know he said two things have never
failed me free speech I think was the
First Amendment and boobs all right it's
a kind of silly glib line whatever but
but the outrage immediately and that
Brooke Baldwin has to issue a statement
on Twitter that he'll never come back on
the show and all that I think it
actually starts corroding our ability to
figure out what we're supposed to
actually react to I would argue that's
actually a feature and not a bug and
that you know the easiest way to
understand what half
at Evergreen what's happening at Reid
and all of the things that look like
variations on this theme is that they
are not actually arguments in the
traditional sense they're insurgencies
and they are effectively attempting to
shape what can be taught what can't be
taught what can be discussed what won't
be discussed and they are shaping policy
in this way and I mean I think maybe the
the most bitter pill in the whole thing
is that there is actually a point at
which that is appropriate all right
there are moments in history in which
your system is so broken that you are
actually justified in resisting its
ability to talk to you influence you and
all of that but we are not there this is
happening and it is entirely
counterproductive so what I would argue
is that we have come to a point where
our environment is so novel I mean so
different even from the world we grew up
in that it is impossible that any
political system or ideology or economic
system that is old enough to have a name
that we would all recognize there is no
one of those that's right
none of them are up to speed right we
actually have to discover a new
mechanism for dealing with the modern
realities that we face and what that is
going to require is license for us to
talk about possibilities most of which
will be wrong and if your response to
hearing something that strikes an off
note is outrage that conversation can't
happen so this instinct to resist a
corrupt and broken system by shutting
down everything that doesn't sound right
is going to prevent us from getting to a
new system which is exactly what we have
to be doing at this moment so then what
do we do about the the truly bad ideas
so when these white supremacists are out
there marching basically saying that by
the color of their skin that somehow
gives them more either more importance
or a more ownership of this country I
mean it's contrary of course to the
Constitution into basic decency and all
that what do we do now
I don't want these people silenced and I
don't I had to defend Richard Spencer
when he got punched I don't I don't want
you know I
the fact that we use Nazi now all the
time but I don't want these people to be
punched for their ideas you actually
make them the victims which is really
what they want they want to claim
victimhood so what do we do though about
the ideas that are truly terrible and
truly dangerous that's that's a great
question so I guess there are two things
one is we have to have better ideas and
confidence than our good ideas and I
think that's part of what's going on
here is that is that I mean you know the
the all of the what I would say the best
ideas in history in Western civilization
are under attack right now the idea of
reason the and idea of individualism you
know I think the free market and and
freedom in general people don't
understand what individual rights the
rule of law looks like and when you get
to a point where especially people are
actually attacking reason free will our
ability to think it disarms people and
they and they have every reason then if
you haven't taught them to think
throughout their lives they have reason
to fear bad ideas because they don't
understand how bad bad ideas function
but let me make one more sort of
practical point which has to do with the
intersection of law and our
understanding of individual right takes
Charlottesville there's a there's
there's a lot of really bad ideas woven
into our laws today and the First
Amendment is no exception now I'm about
as fun as free speech absolutist as you
can find but I think there's something
very wrong with the idea and and this
has been a mistake that the Supreme
Court has made for a long time very
wrong with the idea that number one that
we don't make a distinction between
speech and action we have to make a
distinction in the law between speech
and action and number two there can't be
a right to march on public property the
way the white supremacists did in
Charlottesville it makes no sense it's
not that I'm that I'm against you know
people marching for their ideas they
have to do it I think if you're gonna
have public parks and public streets and
and all the like which we obviously have
we
it's just not fundamentally possible to
say people like white supremacists or
anybody have a right to clog the streets
have a right to march in public parks
think about how the people in
Charlottesville felt and and what they
were confronted with I mean the people
who live there one day a bunch of white
supremacists and Nazis show up literally
carrying torches in their in their you
know public park and then you get a
rival gang showing up and they basically
have a gang war right and the police are
confronted with this idea that somehow
this is free speech that we have to
tolerate this as an example of free
speech it's not free speech I think the
yeah well no is that contrary though to
Skokie versus Illinois where it is yeah
so so I think that that's why I started
by saying I think the Supreme Court has
made a mistake now it's an
understandable mistake but I think it
was it was the wrong decision to say
that you have a literal right to march
on public property it's just not it's
not a right that can be made consistent
with the rights of other people you have
a you're building an inherent conflict
into the law and once people come to see
the right to free speech as Nazis
literally have a right to come to my
town clogged the streets up and and what
they were doing what the white
supremacists were doing an anti-fog both
which I regard basically as morally
equivalent but they're not they're not
in that circumstance they they didn't do
all the exact same things but I mean
imagine what that means a band of people
with helmets on with shields with sticks
and actually carrying torches that's not
an effort to communicate to people
that's an effort to intimidate people
that's I think what the Nazis were doing
in Skokie was that was an effort to
intimidate the people of Skokie Illinois
and I think it's a mistake that the
Supreme Court allowed them to do it now
that's not because they were Nazis it's
because they were engaging in a kind of
intimidation
we can't conflate speech and action
those two things have to be separated
what's the what's the action the march
on public streets that's and and and now
you know one look the the the the best
thing would be if they want to have a
march on private property that's all up
to them and everybody can say screw you
we're gonna stay away I don't wanna I
don't want to do but think of what
happens when there's a march on public
proper
it's a it amounts to my tax dollars as a
person in in Skokie let's say Illinois
or in Charlottesville I have to now pay
for these [ __ ] to come and
intimidate people in my town that's
crazy why should I be forced as a
taxpayer to pay for these guys to have a
March that is designed to intimidate
people they are coming ready for a gang
war and for some strange reason
taxpayers are supposed to pay for that I
am so let me tell you Jesse you're
making the equivalence though with with
an tyfa because again $600,000 yeah it's
the scene auto out of the Berkley coffee
if you treat that as free speech if if
people come to view free speech as
someone has a right to invade my space
and at my expense have a gang war on my
property I'd be against free speech as
well so that the only solution in that
is you have to separate those two issues
we've got to separate to two issues
speech and action have to be made
separate we can't treat all action as
speech action is necessary for speech
speech is a type of action but it can't
be that I have a right to intimidate
other people it's just and and that's
that's definitely true in the law and
Bend man so you don't have a right to
incite violence you don't have to write
a right to threaten people but it's it's
it's I think far too narrowly construed
what constitutes a threat and I think
the white supremacists marching in
Charlottesville was a threat it was
intended as a threat anti-fog coming in
was also a threat it was basically a
gang war at public expense that's insane
people are not going to support free
speech if they see it under those terms
and then finally to the extent we have
public spaces and public parks and the
like it can't be that anybody has a
right to do anything on that on that
property that they want it's it's not
true now in in many ways but it
shouldn't be that we we hold that that
every public space is open to any kind
of speech it just can't be it's not it's
not actually feasible this is why when
you when you hold that that you have a
right to essentially confront others on
public property you necessarily build a
clash into your laws and and it's it
becomes irresolvable people see it as
irresolvable and their own and i think
the logical response is to say well then
let's jettison free speech so you know
no public square' no I think you could
have
squares but they have to be very highly
regulated it's an unfortunate fact I'm
not a fan of saying this I'm right this
is a guy who doesn't like very backwards
here I know so but but I'm not seeing
the libertarians are getting this I know
the libertarians will definitely get
pissed off a lot of people will but but
that's fine I'm a fan of being having
people pissed that mirror I don't mind
it but my point is not it's not that I
want to restrict free speech it's that
you just can't have public property a
public square where anybody gets to go
in there and have what essentially
amounts to a melee or or or a a March
that is intended to intimidate people
that's what the white supremacist we're
in Charlottesville to do I mean you can
tell by everything they did carry
torches for God's sakes it's like they
were going after the monster and that
you know they they surrounded the statue
that's all intimidation tax if you're
gonna have public squares and I mean we
have them right so they are they're a
fact I'm not arguing against the
existence of I mean I you know in a
perfect world yeah we can get rid of but
we have the world in which actually
exists so all I'm saying is given that
we have public property it has to be
managed by the government it's just no
choice it's not I'm not a fan of having
the government manage these things but
the way the Supreme Court I think has
interpreted the First Amendment to allow
this sort of free fall for all or to
interpret a March as the same thing as
us communicating up here it doesn't make
any sense it's I think it's just sort of
metaphysically wrong it's it's it's a
real mistake in that way the way they
view free speech I'm just as if I stand
up now and I threaten to punch you
that's not free speech but it is
communicating something and if if we
allow people to get away with that then
they will come to associate speech and
force and they will jettison speech and
that's actually what's happening on
college campuses I think a lot of
students feel threatened they think God
how do I get away from this stuff
imagine being in Charlottesville and
thinking I don't want what supremacists
on my in my you know in my town how do I
get away with from this that the Supreme
Court has said I have to put up with it
and what's the logical conclusion from
that well then screw Surry free speech
and my answer is you don't have to put
up with what
I thought I heard I heard one clap
there's one very intense clap well it's
interesting because we've done a bunch
of these and I and I've never heard that
argument for and I think there's a lot
of legitimacy to it so I want to move to
the to the Q&A because I usually find
that that's the best part of these whole
things but do you have anything you want
to surprise me on well I mean I do want
to respond a little bit I mean I think
the thing about free speech is it is so
vital to what we are doing that we have
to err in the direction of tiki torches
don't actually sound like speech but we
probably have to allow them and the
proper thing to do is to draw the line
at action but people have to be able to
speak and I would say the idea I think
it's just wrong headed and this is
something that an tyfa and the left are
screwing up badly now the idea that
regulating what can be said is the way
to deal with the hazard is nonsense
right the hazard of what happened in
Charlottesville is that we are at a
point in history where those arguments
begin to resonate and we need to deal
with the reason those things are
resonating right keeping those people
from carrying their torches and
surrounding statues doesn't deal with
the fact that people are feeling boxed
in and they're beginning to turn on each
other in a very tribal familiar way
unfortunately so again I would say what
we ought to do is leave ourselves enough
room to have discussions that allow us
to figure out a way out of the cul de
sac that we find ourselves in rather
than to figure out any way to regulate
speech offensive or not it needs to be
permitted yeah
all right well for me at least this hour
went by incredibly quickly we've got a
couple mics out there to take some
questions from from you guys but I do
want to just kind of wrap this up with
one thought which is I mentioned this to
some of you guys that set this up at the
beginning I went to college from 1994 to
1998 I guess that seems like a long time
ago maybe but it but to me it doesn't
seem like that long ago and I was on
PlayStation 1 what are you what are you
guys on switch switch what the hell is
it all right but it that doesn't seem
like that long ago and I
thinking the scheme of things it is that
long and there is just simply no doubt
that you guys live in extraordinary
times these issues on what you are
allowed to think while you're at college
the place you are allowed you're
supposed to learn how to think this was
not a debate when I was in college I
suspect it was not a debate really when
you guys were in college
and yet it's need to be it is literally
I think the most important thing that
you will learn while you're here
whatever your major is whatever you're
gonna do it the free speech and your
ability to think critically and use
logic and reason will frame everything
else you can do so I thank you guys for
coming out and taking a little time to
exercise that I hope you feel maybe a
little a little more enlightened or
embolden to stand up for what you
believe in and and let's take some
questions and they don't have to all be
nice Jason thank you we have no rules
let's so Professor Weinstein you let's
see Steve alluded to you know sort of
having some appreciation of the value
for free of free speech and Professor
Weinstein you mentioned I think you were
very specific about you know the notion
that that's the only way to grapple with
sort of these unknown problems that are
happening Steve could you go further
into like elucidating and listing the
values the value the good side of having
free speech oh I mean I would put it as
free speech is absolutely essential to
living a good life it's absolutely
essential it's free speech is a
corollary of free thought right to get
along in life we have to think we have
to make choices we live in a social
situation we're social creatures right
so it's a normal to communicate with
other people I mean you can barely I
that barely scratches the surface of
just how important free speech is
typically I think it's put as it's
important to maintaining a free society
which I toll heartedly agree with but I
would say it's more fundamental than
that it's important to living a good
human life and pursuing happiness in the
way that the founders you know thought
of that which I think is the appropriate
way to think about we we all have to
pursue or ought to pursue our own
lives and our unhappiness thinking and
communicating is absolutely essential to
that so it's it's one of the most
fundamental and important rights that we
have as human beings and I don't think
it would be possible to live a proper
human life without it and it's no
surprise that dictatorships always clamp
down on free speech they can't tolerate
big fan Dave
pretty much was so my question is to
Steve when you're saying you know the
guys with the tiki torch and we should
have some you know line in the sand that
you know - shouldn't it shouldn't be
allowed but I don't know if you're
familiar with what happened in Boston
yeah where there was 40 people versus 40
thousand people so where do you draw a
line over there I mean I every single
people I knew they went out and they
were like we're gonna go yeah there's
all these white supremist people coming
in and they're literally I was like dude
you got a virtual signaling yeah but
they were going out and I had fought
with people for 41 but I couldn't be
there but so like when you're saying
that those guys you know we have to
somehow you will come in and control
these people with the ticket arts I do I
don't see the line yes so I like how we
made this about tiki torch em the
greatest enemy I know so I think that's
a great question and part of the reason
that I oppose the current paradigm is
precisely what happened in Boston so the
the so this is the Boston March that
happened not too long after
Charlottesville everybody thought it was
a white supremacist March it wasn't a
white supremacist March it was a bunch
of libertarians I think there were some
other groups that sort of glommed on
doing them or something like that but
notice what happened hat why so that
March was cut short these guys were / or
not wasn't even a March it was a
peaceful demonstration or peaceful just
discussion that's actually how it should
happen it should be what those guys did
in Boston it's peace
if they want to stand on a stage this
happens on on on the mall in Washington
do you see all the time you get a permit
you go you have your talk you stand on
your stage people have the mic and they
speak that speech and yes that's that's
what I would say should happen in the
public square what I'm making a
distinction between is the idea that we
allow people to march around and to
engage in action that isn't strictly
speaking speech it's not because I'm
against action it's because if we're
gonna have public squares they have to
be managed orderly and people's rights
have to be protected and you cannot have
masses of people going around
intimidating people that's what that's
what happened in Charles ville now but
one final point I want to try to keep
this quick if you recall what happened
in Boston or the big complaint of the
organizer of the of the march was it
that the cops on the beat the cops on
the street so to speak that we're
managing that protest they ended up
deciding when to cut off the thing they
ended up sitting there when they were
circled by cops all of whom were
convinced that this was white
supremacists we don't really want to
allow you so we'll sort of wink wink
yeah you can have your speech for a
couple minutes then we'll shut the whole
thing down that's not necessarily
criticizing the individual police it's
we've done that we've achieved the worst
of all possible worlds we thought we
were taking out of government's hands
the ability to make content-based
distinctions instead all we've done is
put it on the cop on the shoulders of
the cop on the street who either as in
Charlotte says well I have to respect
people's right to free speech so there's
nothing I can do when anti-shah and an
white supremacist start fighting unless
they're fighting and now we have an
impossible situation to solve or well I
think these guys really are white
supremacists so you know let's let's
among ourselves decide not to really let
them carry on too long it's the worst of
all possible words and I think that was
an exact example of exactly what happens
when you give this kind of authority to
government and you tell them essentially
that that marches and that protests are
the same as free speech
yeah I think that that the the judge and
the the cops in Boston were rightly
concerned that they would get violence
but it's because we've gone down this
path of allowing violence to happen and
calling it free speech that's the
mistake than I'm saying I'm not saying
no speak speech on public property I'm
saying it has to be managed in a way
that you strictly separate between
action and speech so there's a
distinction right between free speech
and hate speech and one of them is
protected one of them isn't hate speech
is classified as speech that is
basically direct incitement to violence
or discrimination and I want to bring up
two events that happened within the last
year in our area there was one event in
March where there was this bus called
the free speech bus I don't know if you
guys had heard of it but it was this big
orange bus that was touring the country
and on the side of it it said boys are
boys girls are girls that's biology and
so on and it was touring the the cities
in the US and the other event was the
Charles Marie event that happened a week
or two ago which I'm sure you guys are
aware of and while neither of those
events were what I would personally
consider to be hate speech no they
weren't direct calls to violence or
discrimination they were expressions of
those those people's views many of the
arguments on the other side of the
protesters who attended both of those
events was that was either saying that
that form of free speech was actually
hate speech or that it was a form of
free speech that nevertheless incited
violence and discrimination despite not
being a direct call to that so how do
you guys respond to that well I would
argue that there really is no such thing
as hate speech first I mean there's a
direct call to violence which is a legal
issue that is one thing if we directly
threaten each other now now the
authorities can get involved I'll kick
it to you for what it said on the side
of that bus as a biologist yeah what was
the exact quote again boys or boys girls
or girls that's biology as a biologist
would you put this on the hate speech
list no I would put it on the wrong
speech list
yeah it's incorrect so but the point
would be it is a valid argument it is
incorrect it does not make sense whether
we are abstracting from the biology of
other creatures or whether we are
looking at human beings there are
certainly many instances of
cultures that have some sort of
alternative gender to them at the moment
the Kuna of Panama sprang to mind but
nonetheless there are many examples
where evolution may be acting on the
cultural side but has produced something
other than boys and girls and there are
plenty of examples where people switch
and then within the animal kingdom
there's also tons and tons of gender
switching I mean unbelievable stuff so
it is an incorrect argument but the idea
that one cannot deliver it as a
challenge is it not simply true that
boys are boys and girls are girls and
girls are xx and boys are XY you know
that is an argument that is valid and it
does not induce anybody to harm anybody
else so I think the problem is people
want some kind of guarantee about what
biology is going to deliver them on
topics that are sensitive and sorry but
it's not going to happen there is no
guarantee the biological truth of these
things is messy and even even when you
hear that something is cultural and not
biological we are making a fundamental
error designed to save us from some of
what biology has delivered to us as
wrong as this is going to sound our our
culture is equally as biological as our
genes so it is fair to make a
distinction between genes and cultures
to different places that information can
involve and be transmitted but it is not
a distinction between biology and
culture that's not a valid distinction
even though some of my colleagues would
disagree with me on that but but in any
case it's it can't be true that just
because a biological idea is incorrect
or leads to a suggestion that's are
really simplistic that it is oppressive
it can just simply be inaccurate yeah
can I just say one thing about the legal
issues so you equated hate speech with
incitement that's a mistake and it's a
it's the there is no such thing as hate
speech in the law there's incitement in
the law and that's illegal but hate
speech is not a cat it's not I mean you
said it's not a thing I agree with that
but it's not a legal category at all and
that's a real mistake a lot of people
make that mistake and it's a dangerous
mistake although I understand why you
make it because it's prevalent
out there but just to speak to the if
you want the way I think to think about
where the line is between what should be
appropriate speech or legal speech let's
say in speech that can be made illegal
it's essentially if you're actually if
speech is incidental to the use of force
against another person or to a crime
that can be proscribed so fraud is a
good example if you threaten somebody
that can be prescribed because if it's
an actual threat because it's
essentially the same thing as carrying
out force against them it's just you're
doing it your claim you're gonna do it
in the future and then incitement you
can think of as it's kind of a group
threat I'm not carrying out the threat
myself so I'm gonna it's not just I'm
gonna kill you you know right after this
talk is done it's hey everybody join me
together and then we'll kill you after
the talk is done if that's serious
that's incitement but that's the line
the line really ultimately is it's the
use of force against people or the
intention or some sort of a plan to use
force it's not the same thing as I said
something that pissed a lot of people
off that's not incitement so that's the
line we have to keep clear on but I'll
leave it at that first of all thank you
guys so much for coming out tonight my
question for you guys is after Sharla's
Phil after the Boston riots the free
speech movements take a hit at least in
Boston so for all the college activists
for free speech here what do you think
should be the next steps to undo the
damage that Charlotte's will happen I
have to show this little hand after the
second fawcett free speech rally well I
can give you the one that I give every
time I give a speech at colleges which
is you guys must stand up for what you
believe in it sounds sort of cliche and
whatever but the amount of people that
email me constantly are like oh I'm
afraid to put one of your videos on
Facebook or you know my my cousin's not
going to talk to me anymore if I say
this or that this concept is insane I
often talk about on the show that it
seems to me that the bigger threat to
free speech right now at this moment in
time 2017 right now in September I am
NOT that afraid that the government is
coming for my free speech I kind of wish
that that was the fear that I had most
because that's the I that's every sci-fi
movie that I ever watch that's what it's
about right so I kind of wish
that that made sense in my brain what I
fear is that slowly we're just not
saying things we're just simply not
saying things we're cowing people into
silence by the outrage machine that we
were talking about we're in a position
where tenured professors that know that
this man was on the right side of
history and fighting against racism are
afraid to step up and say that we're
we're students all right you know I did
I went to UCLA with Milo and and all
hell was breaking loose I mean they were
spitting in cops faces they were dumping
garbage cans they created a wall a human
wall so they're not against walls they
just don't like Trump's wall you know
and like this concept of being so afraid
of ideas say you know
Douglas Murray who's the guest on my
show tomorrow we taped already I'm gonna
just steal a line that he hasn't even I
don't know that he said it publicly but
I asked him to space a question what
would you tell young people who want to
do what you do because I think Douglas
is basically the next Hitchens I think
he's so clear and concise and honest and
because he's British he has a way of
just you know wood just getting it out
and I asked him that very question and
his answer was you know what the water
isn't that cold and I thought that that
was pretty great that if you put your
butt on the line you might find that all
of the things that you've built up that
you're gonna lose friends or your
professors are gonna turn on you or
whatever else I think you might find
that actually you'll find new allies and
new friends and you will lose some I'll
uh you know I've talked about a lot I've
lost a lot of friends over the last
couple years
not because I'm a racist because I'm not
but because I've started talking about
some of these things but I've gained a
lot of new friends and new allies I
happen to be sitting here with two of
them so I think the best thing you can
do is simply fight for what you believe
in even if it's everything that I don't
believe in I would encourage you to do
that I have a couple things I would add
to that first of all I'm that was pretty
good though that was good
that's good so what I would add are are
a couple things one the problem is the
threshold of offense people are offended
so quickly that they never get around to
hearing the part of what's being said
that they need to hear and so we get
these echo chambers which are absolutely
industrial-strength so one thing is find
the people that you disagree with figure
out which ones you can sit down with and
and talk productively and talk to them
you will be shocked you will be shocked
the the other thing is stop being afraid
to polarize if you hear that somebody is
polarizing one has the sense that that
must be a very bad thing or that having
enemies is a bad thing what you want to
do is be ready to polarize because if
you're not polarizing you're probably
being too timid and what you want is for
the room or the institution or whatever
entity it is to polarize correctly so
that when you look at your enemies and
your allies the allies are the people
that you would want as allies right if
you polarize the room correctly you
don't need that many friends in life so
be bolder don't be terrified by the fact
that it will create enemies and realize
that as you create enemies the quality
of your friend group will go up because
the people who will stand by you in such
circumstances are simply higher quality
I think I think in essence what we both
said there was have less friends which
have less but higher quality there you
go all right professor Weinstein you've
made some great points about biology and
theory of biology I was wondering if you
have any plans to do a YouTube lecture
course similar to other professors who
have moved on from their jobs yes I'm
already trying to do so on patreon and
YouTube I will say probably the problem
for for doing so is that there is a tool
kit that I've been using to teach for
the last 14 years and without presenting
that toolkit in some way that people
have access to all of the parts of it
the ala carte pieces of the puzzle some
of them sound like they might be
flat-out wrong and so anyway I think
what needs to happen is I need to
deliver that toolkit in a book form so
that people have access to the the
assumptions that go into it and the
particular models and then delivering
the particular details of what this
system means or that system or what it
means that people behave in such in such
a fashion those things will make more
sense but anyway I am I wasn't expecting
this turn of events to happen and so it
catches you off-guard and it left me
trying to build that that presence on
the fly in the midst of a lot of other
things but it is very much on my mind as
a thing to do by the way you know with
Brett situation I'm sure some of you
guys saw the the conversation that Brett
had with Jordan Peterson on Joe Rogan's
show and as you said to me today it's
interesting because Brett comes from the
left Jordan comes from the right they've
both suffered from this crush of free
speech on at the academic level and
because of that these guys are absolute
allies now even if you have every
political disagreement known to man
which you may or may not have but it's
actually irrelevant because you're on
the right side of the free speech debate
and that's far more important than
quibbling over every little economic
argument or whatever else well I would
say also you know I think this pattern
will become clearer as more and more
people get pushed out or pushed into the
public eye because of taking a print
we'll stand but it's very clear to me
that Peterson is a principled person who
will have arrived at every one of his
positions for good reason and that to
the extent that he and I might disagree
if I catch him out on something he'll
get on the right side of that issue and
the same goes for me so there is a kind
of ability ability to play right that
adults can interact in a particular way
that does not require agreement and in
fact you have vastly more to gain
talking to someone you disagree with
because somebody will be leveled up by
it at the end of a discussion so you
know let me compare for you on the trip
over I looked at some videos of people
that I disagree with I actually looked
at Ben Shapiro and Richard Spencer and
at the end of that I realized you know
more or less what I expected I looked at
Ben Shapiro and he and I disagree on a
tremendous number of things no question
in my mind we could sit down and have
very productive discussions and that you
know everybody's positions are arrived
at straightforwardly I look at Spencer
there's no there there right there's no
point in having that discussion because
it arises out of such a basic
misunderstanding of fundamental things
that really the point is you're just
wrong and you're just wrong for very
simple reasons that you'd know if you
were interested in finding out if you
were wrong so anyway I would suggest
that for all of you take a look at the
people who you your instinct is you're
on the other side and see what they're
saying and figure out what fraction
actually divides you
thanks guys again for a really
fascinating talk so I'm sympathetic to
your current argument mr. Simpson that
regulation government regulation is
never the solution to these problems
partly because the government has a
monopoly on violence you know this sort
of Randy an idea and but what I think
we're coming around to is that the
implication is that these these things
can be fought based on based out of out
of discussions with people and debates
and rational debates and I'm definitely
believer in that or at least I very much
want to be when I'm being optimistic so
my question is sort of a practical one
how how does one have a discussion with
people who are trying to tear down free
speech which is actually what is
enabling the discussion partly because
the the the the problem is twofold it's
partly because these people are
incredibly intoxicating and very very
able to get people to their side and the
second part is that they're more or less
incapable of listening to something that
they disagree with so I'm wondering
practically how does one have these
discussions I mean I don't think it's my
answer isn't different really from what
Brett and Dave have said I think that at
a certain point if somebody is not
willing to listen and they're stuck in
their position and they're just gonna
scream at you there's nothing much you
can do about that there's there's no
practical answer to that you can try to
appeal to them you can try to find
common ground I think you have to be you
know dogged you have to be calm you have
to be confident but at some point you
have to be willing to say as Brett said
about Richard Spencer there's no there
there these guys aren't listening I'm
not going to waste my time talking to
people who aren't listening the one
thing that I would take issue with your
question is that the idea that these are
this is in any way the majority I don't
think it's even close that I think you
sort of implied that that there are a
lot of people like this and that their
ideas are catching on I mean there are
reasons that their ideas are catching
it's because of more fundamental ideas
but I don't think it's anywhere close to
the majority of students even that that
are opposed to reason on and opposed to
free speech I mean you know they're
they're a poll just I read about a poll
today which is of great concern that
students are very confused about free
speech that some of them think that
shouting people down is appropriate that
like something like twenty percent of
them even think that using violence is
appropriate
now that's one poll but even even
assuming those are the numbers I think
that that doesn't necessarily mean
that's the majority of students and it
was by no means the majority even in the
poll are closed to reason I think you
can reason with most people I think it's
a vocal minority of people who are
opposing free speech and ultimately what
you have to do is you've got to try to
appeal to them and really try to appeal
to their sense of reason and an honesty
but more broadly I mean we have to do a
better job of teaching people in this
country that's a that's something that I
mean I think the issues that we're
talking about here go way beyond the
personal how do you interact with people
and go to more you know broader
philosophical and political issues of
how does a nation ultimately protect the
ideas that are necessary for that nation
to continue and that I mean that goes to
many more fundamental things we have to
you know we've got to reform our
educational system there's a lot that we
have to do but no individual can do that
but if you're not willing to start
learning what ideas led to the erosion
of free speech you're never gonna be
able to get back to or get to a point
where free speech is protected if I
could just jump on that for a second
because by the nature of what I do for a
living where I try to calmly talk to
people and get them to use logic and
reason and all these things I do worry
about what you just said because you use
the word intoxicating and this sort of
hysteria that we seem from both sides
these days where if all of your
intellectual opponents are a Nazi well
that's pretty powerful you you are now
very high up they're very low and that
there's a there's a virtue signaling as
my friend over here said there's a sense
that you're on a mission and I sometimes
do wonder that if we just try to out
logic everybody and out reason everybody
that actually will kind of lose the game
without even realizing it because the
two sides will go so bananas that will
just kind of be caught and pinched off
and I've even seen you can just sort of
sense it online now that there is a
movement that's very anti centrist now
because they're making it sound like we
don't stand for anything because we're
not picking a side in this battle now I
don't think those are the right sides we
should be picking between if we have to
pick between two and I don't think you
have to pick between two but I do worry
about that that look if if any of the
three of us had had a long history of
saying crazy things there probably would
have been protests outside there
probably would have been television
coverage all of those things not as
those that strengthened those ideas are
weakened them it depends on the case I
suppose but I think you're making a
really good point which is can people be
decent try to find answers and care
about liberalism and you know inquiry
and all those things and still win I
guess we'll find out that's really up to
you guys
I would actually maybe add something to
that realize that there is the context
in which any of these confrontations
take place and then there's a context
that you will discover the full
dimension of later and being college
students you'll anticipate it better
than let's say I would at my age but the
conflict in the room is one thing and
then there is how it plays elsewhere and
I want to confess something to you guys
that I haven't said to anybody yet which
is as things were heating up at
Evergreen you know this took place over
the course of a year and so it was a
very intense experience and very
isolating as it was happening and the
world was unaware and uninterested in it
so I was looking at other models of how
how this is unfolding and I actually did
some I spent some time watching Peterson
and I remember watching Peterson face
down this one particular group in a you
know some sort of a
lecture hall and they are shouting vile
things at him and he is sitting there
very calmly right and he is speaking
back in a way that tells you that he's
not frightened he's not backing down
he's not putting up his fists and the
thing is at the time I knew that's a
skill I actually possess but I needed to
be reminded that that was the skill that
was going to get me through at the point
the thing boiled over which I felt was
very likely to happen at some point I
didn't know that they were going to come
to my class and disrupt that but in any
case I would say part of the answer is
think through now what you will do in
the face of an unreasonable response and
being more reasonable is very powerful
being more reasonable without being
right that's the thing you don't want to
advertise weakness but there is strength
in simply being able to say no actually
the accusation you're leveling at me
isn't true the arguments you're making
aren't right and I'm confident in that
one caveat as I would say before you
decide to to dig in on such a position
make sure that you do have it right your
position to be dead right first and then
stand your ground and and you'll be all
right
sorry to cut off that next question but
we're just about out of time I just want
to take a minute and thank our panel
speakers for a great discussion today on
behalf of the Harvard libertarian Club
we we frequently like to joke that our
meetings are our safe space for free
speech so if you're interested in having
these kinds of discussions with people
who are going to be okay with whatever
kind of ideas you throw out there
definitely come find us we can add you
to our email list and you can find out
when our next meeting is you realize you
just said safe space to all of our
YouTube subscribers right yeah so I just
wanna thank our speakers and I hope
everyone has a great night if you're
interested in either of our two groups
then come talk to us afterwards but have
a nice night everyone
[Applause]
you